I don't care about the product uh if I
don't like the person shark Tank's Damon
John filing a restraining order against
former contestants I'm Al Bubba Baker
owner of the d-bone baby back rib steaks
nearly a decade after the high profile
entrepreneur invested in their company
but I think I'm going to take them
thank you congrats guys the baker family
took aim at Damon in a Los Angeles Times
profile claiming he's taken over their
business and cut them out of profits we
think it's going to be a great success
we are prepared to put the baby back rib
Burger in our 3 000 locations before
Shark Tank our sales were 154
000. it's been three years and sales are
now at 16 million dollars and I just
can't believe it shark tank is like
shopping for a house you see a house you
go check it out put a bid on it it's the
same thing on the tank they don't say
what's wrong with anything of course now
rep for Damon fires back in a statement
to ET saying it is unfortunate that it
has come to this and that the legal move
comes after the family slanderous social
media posts at best it's not true and
that's me being kind Damon's team says
the family is attempting to undermine
their Business Partnership what is it
that you're thinking when someone walks
in front of you well first of all I'm
thinking of the business what is it
right is it scalable how will I make a
profit meanwhile Damon's also pled his
case on social media so I'm making this
video to address this LA Times article
that Al Bubba Baker and Brittany Baker
intentionally broke the confidentiality
and put out and shop to this reporter
their online damn they're harassing me
at this point and putting up a lot of
falsities and I will not stamp that I'm
always going to stand up for myself